then me and Bob Odenkirk got offered to
write a Chicago super fans movie like
the Bears that thing I cre that's a
characters I created with Bob at
Saturday Night Live right and like that
was really exciting I was going to write
it and I was going to be in it so what
happened oh well you know it's like it's
like the Hans and France movie it was
like too crazy it was it's like I got
even with Lauren Michaels even with
Lauren Michaels
yes even with Lauren Michaels that one I
could not I could not get that P same
same with the Hans and frons movie we
just they were just too crazy
for Paramount or whomever the company
was uh that did Hans and fr this one was
Paramount and I I don't know it was a
great it was a great script uh we did it
later at a charity event and it killed
so and and and is it still too it's too
late oh yeah well first of all Chris
passed away you may have
heard uh and um yeah I mean we've done
things in Chicago but after Chris passed
away I was like I never want to do
George has done the super fan character
on SNL I've had him go back but I never
wanted to do it without Chris I never
wanted to it just seemed wrong to
sustain it on Saturday Night Live I've
done it in Chicago with George like
little appearances but right never
wanted to do but I just thinking just a
concept and you can do it with other
actors you've never considered that like
even redoing that um I don't know no I
mean it's funny because that's like a
catchphrase that won't die well that's
why I'm saying it's so funny like in
Chicago and or even on na on Sports
broadcasts that you constantly hear that
when people talk about the Bears they
still go that bears a bears yeah and
that came from what how did you come up
with that well I was so I gave up
standup comedy because I couldn't
sustain I couldn't motivate myself to go
at 1:30 at night I just couldn't do it
and then I ran into Tim kazarinski he
was an you know Tim I know who he is he
was a a cast member yes he had just been
hired he had done like two shows at
Saturday Night Live and I recognized him
on the street because that's what how
level of nerd I was comedy nerd Tim
karinski and he was like you recognize
me and then I told him that I had done
standup and that I just didn't really
know what to do with it and he said you
should try sketch if you like sketch you
could go to Second City they have a
class uh players Workshop it's called
you could take it you could do it in a
summer and when he said that I was like
ding ding ding because I was inic
commitment phobe uh but a summer I'll do
it so I moved to Chicago for a summer
and then I met all these great people
Chicago for people who are into sketch
comedy it's I still think it's the best
place to get started because it's really
about doing great work and focusing just
on that and there's so many venues where
you can do sketch comedy and uh Still
Still yeah in Chicago not in other
cities they they have these classes
right UCB or whatever in other cities
but Chicago I mean I didn't get into
Second City I just formed a group with
friends of mine and then we funded it
ourselves it was in a very small theater
and we managed to get like the Chicago
Tribune we had a really pushy guy in our
group who like got
Tribune to to review it and he gave it a
great review and that's how we got then
we got moved to a bigger theater and we
a big success and then Franken and Davis
saw
us